what do you think about saralyn oh I
don't really think about her all that
much I mean obviously I'm a fan of her
early work which bulbs satirized some
celebrated youth culture's obsession
with sex but I do wonder as a third wave
feminist if it's even possible for women
to reclaim their sexuality in this
deeply entrenched patriarchal society or
if claiming to do so it's just a lie we
tell ourselves so we can more
comfortably cater to the male gaze what
do you know on the other hand I worry
that conversations like this one often
dismiss her as a mere puppet of the
industry that's my same worries capable
of engaging in these discussions herself
obvious smart evangelization which is
itself a product of the deeply misogyny
live in but like I said I don't really
think about her all that much okay well
good was more asking like what do you
think about her living here oh right
well what was your relationship like
with her when you were working on the
show it was very good very professional
where did you go to college honey
college is for ugly people who can't tap
dance I want to be an architect
sweetheart mommy didn't do what mommy
did to that star surge producer so that
you could be an architect all right take
it sleazy everybody wait what are you
doing this weekend I don't know I'll
probably just go to the amusement park
maybe the circus fly kite on the beach
watch the sunset then I'll head back to
my place to watch any number of Disney
Princess movies while eating ice cream
straight from the tub yeah like I want
has been my weekend hanging out with a
little girl like good one you should
write for the shouts and murmurs see you
Monday
do the makeup they were putting on you
was not for the show it was just for the
weekend what does that matter I'm just
trying to understand the story do you
think it's possible that you inviting
Sara Lynn into your house now is your
way of compensating for no Diane I'm
just helping out a friend I'm not trying
to play out some weird sick dad fantasy
or resolve a deep guilt for past neglect
or even try to retroactively Lee fix my
own childhood by recreating someone
else's and I'm especially not doing all
those things at once okay
what happened did somebody hurt my
precious baby
[Music]